hello everybody how's everybody doing
hope you're doing better than me
this is rational science
directly from Frankfurt Germany
and we have a great day today
uh even though I'm not doing that well
not yet at least I'm recovering from a
bacterial disease known as
erysapellas
and it attacks uh my leg my left leg in
this case leaves the anything below the
knee red
and if you don't stop it on time well it
could go after your lymph nodes and do a
lot of damage
anyways I was out for about a week a
little over really eight eight days and
it came out of the hospital a couple
days well was it Friday Friday night
that's when I came out
anyways
um some people had something to say
about that and uh it's usually people
who
have problems with the establishment
right
um
I think they do a little more politics
than they do Health okay they we're
limited to health that'd be great but
they immediately go into this uh issue
of you know pharmaceutical companies and
doctors making a lot of money you know
and so it takes away from the discussion
because that's a political issue it's
not so much not that it's uh wrong or or
you know it's it's an opinion right but
the point here is that it takes away
from the health issue and here's one
fellow who said the following he says uh
about that right he said he
so this he says the West way to get your
health back is to go to your natural
diet raw vegan diet
[Laughter]
I'm gonna die
uh you know our natural diet is meat
I'm sorry to tell you
you know those uh Spears that we that
our ancestors had uh fifty thousand a
hundred thousand years ago
they didn't use them to hunt lettuce or
you know pumpkins they didn't use them
to uh bring down apples now they use
them to kill animals
and that's what we ate that's what our
you know ancestors ate they just killed
an animal and lived one more day that's
that's what it was so that is our
natural
diet okay now we uh changed the diet
some maybe somewhere between 10 and 20
000 years ago when we invented
Agriculture and started eating
um things that we collected maybe nuts
berries whatever
but until then I think it was uh I think
a hundred percent meat I'm not sure if
that number is correct but they say that
neanderthals were like 98 99
uh meat eaters and I think yeah that's
that's where both of these hominids you
know were we were all meat eaters then
we changed our diet and today we have we
went even further some people don't eat
meat at all even though that's
maybe what our bodies are used to eating
because we have this long uh evolution
in which you know we ate meat now some
people don't eat it at meat for ethical
reasons you know they believe that
you're not supposed to kill animals
torture them that kind of thing that we
are abusing animals and all I can tell
you man is that anything related to
ethics is religion
okay
ethics man invented ethics uh Mother
Nature doesn't understand ethics she has
a lion eating you know the deer and
that's all she understands uh
the the the lion doesn't go on Sundays
to pray for salvation because he killed
a deer you know so no that stuff about
ethics that's religion that's got
nothing to do with
Health at least you know now is uh meat
better than veggies veggies better than
meat
well you know I had a pet lion once and
I decided to test that and I fed them
lettuce for about two weeks
until he died
and so I don't think veggies is a good
diet for you know for mammals especially
Lions I think I proved that
hahaha so you know I don't know
um again I think it's our natural diet
to eat meat we've gotten away from it a
lot of people because of ethical reasons
uh which has very little to do with what
our stomachs can digest you know you
take a cow I don't think you can feed it
meat for a whole month because it'll
what will happen to the cause the same
thing that happened to my lion which is
the cow will die
so never do that to to uh vegetarian cow
and feed it mean and don't eat don't
feed vegan diets to a lion that's my
recommendation okay anyways this fellow
continues and he says the following says
right now you are in the hands of
barbaric
barbaric butchers who have no clue about
any disease bacterias are your friends
oh you tell that to my leg they consume
dead matter within your body yeah pretty
soon I'll be dead
oh
killing them is the worst you can do
okay so sad but it's your decision
either take your health into your own
hands or be at the mercy of it fools
that prescribe toxic chemicals for 100
years and didn't manage to discover what
creates disease in the first place a
pseudoscientific mockery modern medicine
is
um yeah people have strong opinions
especially in this day and age when
there's so much information on the
internet
you know and so everybody's a doctor
today they can tell you what's good for
the heart what's good for the liver uh
you know the kidneys Etc they know
everything and
and a lot of people are into that in
looking at all these little details you
know and saying oh I know how to cure
this and that and so they become uh you
know doctors internet doctors you know
they get all this information from the
internet and one of the things I'll say
about that you know you'll find doctors
on both sides of the issue sometimes
some have this Theory another guy has
that theory and they don't see eye to
eye and so if you choose this one
because that's your leading well then
that's what you're going to believe
that's all there is to it I personally
um
believe that there are such things and I
do make that assumption that there are
viruses and bacteria some bacteria are
good most of them are bad
okay
um and yeah when you have bacteria in
your body and they start attacking your
system uh people say well the the reason
it attacked you is because you did not
have defenses meaning you did not take
care of yourself you were weak and the
bacteria took advantage you know some
people have that theory okay and that's
to some degree true in fact this um war
between these two general currents has
been going on for over a hundred years
and here's a two people who started that
war one is Antoine Beacham and he argued
that microbes became dangerous when the
health of the host the individual right
it's terrain or environment right
deteriorated and on the other side we
have uh Mr Louise Lewis Pasteur which is
the one who triumphed uh over the
following decades right all the way to
today so the germ theory of disease
describes how sicknesses are caused by
bacterial infections as well as by
viruses that invade ourselves or else by
genetics aging and accidents and
personally I subscribed to that second
view you know uh hang me at dawn you
know send a posse after me but that's
that's the one I subscribe to I like
that theory I think it's a intelligent
Theory okay and yeah you know some
people take the uh view of the first guy
of B jump and I'll tell you something
else
um once uh I was given a book uh how to
cure just about everything I guess you
know they were insinuating that in the
book anyways uh by eating lemon
um uh onion and
um garlic the three miracle cures for
anything in the body you know they
didn't put jalapenos in there
so um is that true can you cure
everything with these three things well
some people have these beliefs you know
and they or they subscribe to those
theories and okay so everybody gets to
choose you know what they uh subscribe
to I guess you know all I can tell you
is uh I like the theory of bacteria
especially when it comes to Eris Palace
why because
um they hit it on our nose every time
and we already know the symptoms my
lower leg below the knee gets red
um
I get uh you know nausea dizziness
and that lasts about a day until they
start giving me antibiotics and we know
that once they feed me the antibiotics
it takes two weeks three weeks to get
rid of it completely and I've done this
already four times I've had areas of
pills four times like every three years
so for the last 11 12 years I've had
this thing
and as far as I know it comes through
the cracks in my heels you know there's
these I do have dry skin in my feet I've
had it for about that same amount of
time maybe anywhere from 12 to 15 years
now I lost count and I think that's
where they come in to the body
and I should be more careful with you
know putting some barriers there that's
that's what I think I've got to do I
propose to my doctor the one who took
care of me that maybe because it comes
like every three years like regularly
that maybe it's not that com that they
come into my feet but once you have it
in your body they kind of go dormant for
three years and then somehow you know
they get excited and you can come out
and do their damage
and she told me that that's not true
that uh bacteria will not last that long
before it gets activated or that
something activates it so there are
theories you know and uh you know I
can't be sure of any of these for sure
I'm not I'm not into that business at
all I don't care too much about that I
just look at the diseases or ailments
that I have and I try to fix those and
that's it I don't go beyond the Call of
Duty finding out you know how do I fix a
heart how do I fix the kidneys I don't
get into any of that not interested at
all in the subject okay another fellow
says the following he says uh what is
the source
killing it with antibiotics only to have
it reoccurring over and over isn't a
very good solution agreed is this that
in this day and age I would even be
looking at my water supply
what am I supposed to find there I guess
bacteria I guess that's
being insinuated here
um yeah could be the problem is that I'm
the only guy getting infected in my
house
and uh so I think it's it's coming
through the cracks of my heels
uh that I can believe especially these
days I had big big cracks there that
were even bleeding so I went out for a
second that they entered through those
channels so what can I tell you you know
different people have different theories
or or subscribe to different theories
and it's fine everybody takes care of
their own body in any way they can
okay anyways uh let's get on with some
of the uh Extinction stuff and uh the
longevity of humans okay here's one
fella his name is Kurtz Weil and this
fellow is a fanatic of um what is it of
the singularity you know Singularity is
that point
uh in technology right think of
Technology there's that point in
technology where the robots kind of take
over and they become a little more
intelligent or more capable you could
say in figuring out things than humans
and so now because they have this great
ability right that we kind of you know
imbued in them that we programmed in
them now they take that and they develop
even at a faster rate all this uh
knowledge
and so now they can create new things
that we can't even imagine or haven't
imagined and the robot just take over
and they just keep uh growing in in
knowledge exponentially
that's the idea it's called The
Singularity the point at that where the
the uh
intelligence or knowledge expands that
uh starts expanding at an exponential
rate that not even humans can catch up
because you know the machines can do it
better than us that's the notion okay
and here we have his name is Kurzweil
there we have it and what he's talking
about lately is immortality he says
we're seven years away from achieving
immortality
okay so what is it um
all right
immortality possibly reads as soon as 20
30. artificial intelligence is what will
make it happen
AI right Kurzweil believes that our
technological medical progress will grow
to the point that robotics he dubs them
uh Nanobots right little bugs that go
into your
um bloodstream and your body in general
right and they go after the they know
you know they're trained uh programmed
whatever to go after the bacteria the
viruses that cause harm in your body
that's the notion behind this will work
to repair our bodies at the cellular
level turning disease and aging around
thanks to the continual work of robotic
know-how and then voila
immortality
okay so uh good we're at the doorsteps
of immortality now I I've got first the
problem with immortality okay I would
not like to be immortal okay the thing
that God's you know the Eternal God's
most envying man is his mortality can
you imagine being around for eons and
eons and eons not even being able to die
you stab yourself you shoot yourself and
you can't kill yourself and you're still
conscious and you see the whole thing
over and over and over again
I don't think so you know uh another
thing is like to say well I would like
to live 200 years
that's different okay but leaving living
an eternity I don't think it's desirable
that's one issue the other one is that
if we allow everybody to live forever
you know we got a problem because the
question now what happens to the kids
are we gonna be producing more kids and
just multiplying the population on the
planet because the old don't die in the
young keep growing
do we stop
um having children
you know give me a solution for that
okay that's that's where we need a
solution not to say hello I want to be
immortal well that's you
you know but uh what does it do for the
world assuming we could achieve it which
is absolute nonsense you know but that's
a separate issue but again what's the
goal you know are we going to
overpopulate the planet until we were so
many that we just fall off the planet
whatever
okay and um uh talking about nonsense in
uh science here we have another big uh
nonsense in science and it's uh people
who think that the aliens
are here they're at least in our
neighborhood okay and these are not
people from the streets you know they're
bums that just have an opinion these are
people supposedly studied at least 10
years at the University and they have
phds okay and here it is here's this
fellow
comes from two the notice comes from two
uh different uh sources one is Fox News
says Pentagon officials suggest alien
Mothership in our solar system could
send many probes to Earth and of course
in that article they mentioned this
fella which is also mentioned in
Scientific American astronomer Avi lib
says aliens have visited and he's not
kidding the Harvard University Professor
explains a shocking hypothesis and calls
out what he sees as a crisis in science
yeah and uh where do they get this idea
they found this um this cigar shaped
cylindrical shape uh asteroid you could
call it right uh coming towards us and
they said that because of its itinerary
it comes out of the solar system
and so they say look you're not looking
at a rock what you're looking at is some
kind of spaceship or something that the
Martians you know the uh
ETS whatever
um chipped off and sent to Earth you
know they have all these theories on
what that rock is because it came out of
the solar system and they believe this
is the first messenger that we get from
um another civilization that's
essentially what they're saying is the
um
[Laughter]
okay so uh this is on the news lately
um I don't know what to tell you uh
there is no way
and I'm on record for this I've got a
video a couple videos on it there is no
way that life of any kind can travel
interstellarly
I said it okay I'm on record there's no
way that life of any kind can survive a
trip that is Interstellar it's
irrational to propose such a thing and
all these people you know they they're
hoping that some bug
travels on some kind of you know
cigar-shaped or asteroid or whatever and
comes to our neighborhood and that
that's how life started here they call
it Pine spermia that the bug crawled out
of the rock you know the vehicle it was
traveling in and then somehow you know
contaminated our planet with life
that's the general idea and uh somehow
from here on we'll do the same thing to
someone else we're gonna send or maybe
when the earth explodes or whatever
there's a supernova any mechanism you
can think of then somehow these bugs
I'll call them bugs for lack of a better
word uh travel to another star system
and there they do the same thing over
again with a
planet which is predisposed to have life
that's the notion and
it's all garbage nonsense poppycock no
life cannot travel uh interstellarly
okay and uh now I'm gonna get into that
here but I do have a video on that and
you can look it up it's the uh what the
pioneers
uh what is it
um
not sure what the title of it is but
it's got to do with the Pioneer probes
that went out of our solar system that
we sent out there uh to maybe contact
some other civilization or let them know
that we're here that sort of thing uh
absolute nonsense we'll never see or
hear from another civilization and what
little time remains for us here on Earth
and uh neither will they hear from us
when humans are gone out of our planet
nobody will even know that we ever
existed what's the purpose of life to
live day by day so drink your beer every
day make sure you're happy and you'll be
okay nothing bad will happen to you
okay so here we have some problems that
we've had that affect our global economy
probably uh a uh give us a hint of what
may happen with man's Extinction the
possibility of Extinction
the likelihood of Extinction
UBS bought credit Swiss okay they went
under the other day uh then they had a
problem with First Republic and they
also had a problem with you know the um
Silicon Valley Bank and uh what was the
other one signature bank okay so some
banks are failing
and the question is is this a problem is
this just uh an accounting procedure is
this just a way to justify mergers
and it was the issue of whether the FED
should back some of these Banks you know
like cover all the deposits if the the
FED should only cover up the 250 000
which is what the law mandates otherwise
you're sticking your hand in the pockets
of
you know taxpayers to pay for something
they didn't vote for that sort of thing
so there's a lot of that going on but
the question is you've got uh banks with
that are failing
and can you imagine a run on
bigger Banks
many of them all of them
uh what would that do I mean imagine
everybody's just going out there and
asking for their money
what are they going to give them we
don't even have cash to give everybody
out there you know
so let's hope it never happens but I
think it will okay
I don't know how soon but I think there
will be a run on the big Banks and
that'll be the end of man essentially
because once money is no more months
money is gone we
don't have any faith in God anymore you
know we become atheists in money uh then
who will produce the food and who will
distribute it and for what why would
they do such a thing for your health
I thought they were in business for
money
okay and um this is uh gives you an idea
how the federal lending to Banks uh this
week according to this Source bestopedia
says that it even surpasses the one in
2008 financial crisis you know
so keep in mind there's a lot of stuff
going on in the banks and they just try
to keep calm everybody calm saying no no
you'll get your money don't worry you
don't you don't have to rush to the bank
and get your money out none of that
it's a sound system
why because imagine if they said the
opposite panic panic time to panic
be the end of man of course he got a
rude and they got a cheerlead you know
that's what they got to do
okay
here we have uh another issue uh defense
budget speeds towards 1 trillion with
China in mind because of China you know
the Pentagon is spending a little more
money because they have to cover the
bases out there in the Pacific okay and
uh so they have bases in every country
in Philippines and uh Japan and some
other Islands there that's one issue the
other one is you know they need more
ships to counter the growing threat
right of China which is putting a lot of
boats underwater and claiming some of
the waters to be uh
uh you know belonging to the country and
not international waters and that sort
of thing and that's something for you to
keep in mind as well that in Taiwan you
know the Straits of Taiwan if China were
to uh
uh you know grab a hold of time one be
make it part of the mainland China the
Communist world right
that straight was suddenly become not
international waters anymore but you
know it's that's my that's those are are
personal Waters those are our country's
water
because you know there's this limit on
uh International limit on how those
things are handled you know what uh how
far from the coast
um your country still extends right and
so if China would happen to grab a hold
of Taiwan and Taiwan becomes part of the
motherland you know China then that uh
the Taiwanese Straits
would be a private Lake no more
international waters
so keep that in mind that's one of the
reasons the United States is a little
worried about that okay that happening
not that it's going to happen anytime
soon but you know there there could be
an issue there okay
okay and um
here's uh
one problem that's out there you know
the U.S households are spending now more
a percentage a greater percentage of
their incomes on rent okay and uh so you
know this uh they said it used to be 30
but now it's going over that okay so
it's a little worrisome especially for
people who are at the bottom uh rung of
uh income
and maybe because of that we have this
we have uh tent cities popping up in
many cities around the country around
the United States not only around the
United States I see them everywhere I
see them you know uh I was in Buenos
Aires and I saw them there in Buenos
Aires Argentina tent cities
and I'm sure those are not the only two
countries that have them these 10 cities
are going to be popping up in many
cities and I'm not sure what the
governments are going to be doing about
that you know I mean what are they going
to do uh violate their rights
to sleep on the streets
you know keep them from one part to the
other I don't know I don't know how
they're going to solve that problem it
would be interesting to find out anyways
and talking about uh Taiwan a minute ago
here we have the countries that um
recognize Taiwan as a country okay and
the reason I bring this up is Honduras
now changed its tune and says it's going
to recognize mainland China as the real
China and not Taiwan it was forced to
relinquish its Embassy in Taiwan and you
can see there's relatively few countries
some of them might switch around again
because they'd rather have business with
mainland China than with Taiwan simply
because of the volume and what it can do
for their own countries but the funny
thing about this is that the United
States was putting the pressure on
Honduras not to severe ties with
um with Taiwan
and it turns out that the United States
doesn't officially recognize
so it's kind of like a contradiction
like I'm sure in private the Honduran
said hey you guys don't recognize Taiwan
you want us to continue recognizing it
you know it's like defeating the purpose
you know so it was uh shocked or not
shocked but surprised that uh Vatican
has ties with Taiwan and I guess it
doesn't have a China I didn't check but
I'm assuming that's the case
okay and finally another issue on the
side you know and that's that you know
Western sanctions have weakened the
Dollar's dominance as India buys Russian
oil with
other currencies specifically with
arugul the rebels
so they're exchanging rubles now over
there and uh or maybe breaks for all we
know in other words they're getting away
from the dollar because they for two
reasons one is the United States uses
that as a weapon and that's the way they
perceive it and the other one is that
you know they really want to diversify
so that they don't rely on a single
currency for whatever reasons and so uh
there's other countries uh Brazil and
Argentina among them you know that are
talking about getting a new coin that
will help commerce between those two
countries so they create a new currency
locally
and that's so interesting because you
know it takes away from the dollar
and just in case you know the dollar was
not always around before that it was the
pound the British pound
okay and so you know and I guess in the
days of the Romans
it was the Dinars or whatever
so uh yeah money does change and uh some
money
people like somebody people don't like
people don't like me paying uh for their
things in Vietnamese currency I don't
know why it's backed by the Vietnamese
government but nobody seems to want it
or Argentine pesos yeah so uh money is
not money is not money there's money and
there's money and there's money people
accepting there's money that people
don't accept
so what happens when the dollar becomes
money that people don't accept can that
possibly happen
food for thought
okay uh so let's move on here to uh the
subject matter today and which is space
what is space can anybody tell me
well we have a problem because uh you
know uh to this day nobody has been able
to define or tell us what space is
and you say well because nobody thought
about it
well not true uh it turns out that the
word space and the analysis of space has
been around at least since the days of
the Greek ancient Greeks right uh
Classical Greece and I'm sure it's been
there before that as well the today we
have the record starting there but I'm
sure that other cultures even before the
Greeks maybe the Sumerians the Egyptians
you know the Babylonians they probably
dealt with these subjects as well uh but
very little of that survives today so we
have to say that it started with the
Greeks so let's start with the Greeks
okay here we have our famous father from
the other day who we were discussing
place now we're going to discuss space
okay uh it's a little different you know
place you got to think of as a location
or position like I like to say it's the
site occupied by the
object itself it's like the volume
occupied by the by the object itself
okay that's different in space that
thing that's out there between you know
the Earth and the Moon
that's you know it's kind of like a
different uh space space is not placed
in places not space
uh place would be the volume occupied by
the moon space is the stuff between you
know the Moon and the Earth that sort of
thing okay so we're going to do space
okay in the side confusion even though
we will okay so here's permanentees this
is essentially what he was saying he
says the one is finite
what's the one the one is the universe
uh also being you know they kind of
mixed all these Concepts being Universe
gods
the one it was like all one in the same
thing it had these Notions kind of mixed
up they never really differentiated them
clearly and say look this is what
exactly what I'm what I'm talking about
they never did that and so they kind of
went back and forth like you know what
I'm talking about you know I'm talking
about the one you know what is the one
well it's you know it's being okay
what's being well it's the universe uh
what is Universe you know space and so
it's like you know they kept switching
these things around kind of in their
analysis and so you have to be careful
what are they talking about what was the
context for almost every line that they
wrote
and one of the things you should note is
that you know Parmenides wrote like
poetry so this is a poem so to speak
they like to say things in a in a way
that they would Rhyme or that they you
know told a little story a little
different than Plato who would go into
and and Socrates who would go in there
and do dialogues between people
imaginary dialogues which came out of
their dial real everyday dialogues and
then you have people like Aristotle
which did a more objective analysis you
could say where he he didn't go into
dialogues specifically or into poetry he
went in there and analyzed the words
okay so you have these three different
um
hand-me-downs from the Greeks okay we
got all three versions okay so this all
says being as complete and homogeneous
like a line
okay and being is everywhere
so of course if being as everywhere uh
it's everything like God is everything
right or the universe is everything
anyway you want to look at that space
time is everything right
and but he says the one is finite
and the question is what's how what's
outside of this finite mess what gives
its shape if it's finite what continues
okay that was the question
and he said he would say that there's
nothing outside of it because
the universe being the one is everything
you got it I hope you got that
okay that was his answer to that okay so
here we have uh fellow who followed him
Melissa's he was also in the iliatic
they were called known as eliotic
because they came from Little Town of
that name uh that was in southern
southwestern Italy okay in the boot
and even though Melissa was from Samus
he he went over there and was from the
same school but he eventually ended up
with a different notion than Parmenides
he says the one has to be infinite
the guy said Finance this guy says
infinite okay the uh for otherwise it
would be limited by something another
being or void
okay so yeah more or less it's like if
it's finite what continues and parmenis
would say well it's everything
so there is no other thing outside of
everything
okay and this guy said well you know if
it's finite then it's got to be
something that is next to it or around
it or whatever and he said there is only
one being and no void okay so he said
that uh his his change was that uh no
it's not finite it's infinite that's why
it's everything
okay so took a little twist to uh
parmittedy's notion okay and then we
have this fellow who comes obviously I'm
not touching up on everybody who was in
between right there's too many Greeks
that dealt with this issue but we go to
the next main guy which is Plato okay
and what does Plato say well he says
if the one does not have Parts it cannot
have a beginning middle and end
okay if something has no beginning or
end it is infinite
the one is therefore infinite and can
have no shape
infinite obviously no shame right I
agree there with him right if it's
infinite it has no shape an object is
that which has shape
is space an object is it a thing
or is it a concept so he hasn't answered
that because he never defined a word
object or the word concept and if they
did they never use their definition
anyways
all shapes the round and the straight
presuppose some form of limit or part
round is that whose limit
whose limits are equidistant in every
direction from the middle okay straight
is that whose middle stands before the
two limits okay
the one is without parts
therefore has to be infinite okay so he
was another infinity guy right together
with Melissa's they concluded that uh
Universe being the one whatever you want
to call it is infinite but then comes
his student Aristotle and he says
something different he says there is a
distinction between parts and limits
okay in contrast to limits Parts can
measure out the whole
if the one is assumed to be a whole that
has Parts the one can still be
understood as being finite okay so the
fact that it's made out of parts does
not take away from its finiteness
despite being limited the one has
beginning middle and end otherwise it
would be a whole as well as shape either
straight or round
so he says that doesn't have to be
infinite in order to be made of Parts
we're talking about two different things
essentially saying okay and that's where
the Greeks more or less left it
then came uh countless
analysts especially from uh the
Christianity you know the uh the
educated people in those days were monks
and uh Bishops and Cardinals right and
so those are the ones who were the
scientists okay A little contradiction
if you compare it to today but that's
the way it was okay so here we have uh
well I gotta finish up on Aristotle here
uh he tried to analyze space and he says
uh he went to prove or show or whatever
argue that it's not a total void okay
I'm sorry that it is a total void no I'm
sorry is it in if space that it's not a
total void in other words there's always
something inside this a space an empty
space it's it's got something in it okay
there's no such thing as total empty
space as
um some of the others uh Greeks argued
okay so he said if space is 3D and space
is a body
means two bodies are in one place
because you have the space
that the body occupies plus the 3D body
so how can two bodies be in the same
place okay so this was his starting
point a cube does not display space like
it would if inversed in water you put a
cube in water displaces water you put a
cube in space Aristotle says it can't
displace space
okay because kind of space kind of seeps
in there you know if we remove
temperature or weight cube the cube
occupies same volume of void
okay so you have all these
uh properties these attributes
and with or without them the cube
occupies the same space
so the question is can you put more
attributes in a thing and say it's uh
it's the same thing
in other words uh can the attribute and
the cube occupy the same space
and if not then you know how about space
you know can space occupy the same space
as the cube
so they got into all these
um
logical you could say uh uh
analysis okay
motion would be instantaneous and
Perpetual okay uh without resistance
object would move in any direction and
so he Likens it to a uh plenum he says
uh all bodies whatever their weights
would fall with equal velocities natural
motion meaning gravity he called that
natural motion you know because
nothing pushes or pulls on it but as
soon as you let it go well it falls
downward so he says that's natural
motion of the pencil so he called
brevity natural motion and he says
because bodies with different weights
and sizes movement at different speeds
through a plenum
so moving sideways which is force equals
mass times acceleration is that the same
thing as moving downwards by gravity
which is force equals gravitational
constant G mass mass divided by distance
squared are those two equations the same
and Einstein said well yeah they are you
know the principal equivalence and but
he never knew why okay but that's
another story for another day but here
we can see his logic he's saying look if
you move sideways the more resistance
the more water like area offers less
resistance than one right so you have a
fish or maybe a bird moving through the
water and moving through air it's going
to move faster through air or a cube or
whatever you want to move through there
so he says uh uh obviously
the more resistance there is the the
slower an object goes and he was
thinking also without doing the
experiment again uh that if you drop two
objects the heavier one would fall
faster why because it's it's like the
plenum going sideways is no different
than going downwards gravity is no
difference in force equals mass times
acceleration and so obviously if you
have some kind of resistance it's going
to take longer for a bigger more massive
object than it would for a lighter one
and he extrapolated that to gravity and
says the same things that happen to
gravity which it doesn't
but that's how he concluded okay anyways
for many years they uh had um debates on
this issue they essentially all worked
off of Aristotle okay and they never
came up with anything different uh than
what Aristotle uh came up with and
here's one fellow Thomas Aquinas he was
one of them here's another fellow these
are folks that dealt with the issue of
space okay here's another Francisco
Suarez he was a Spanish priest you could
say
um
I think he was a cardinal and
um you had others like uh this uh fellow
estaculus okay eustachius and he also
discussed space but never made any
Improvement on what Aristotle talked
about they just analyzed Aristotle uh
ad nauseam and never change anything
essentially they they didn't they didn't
come up with a definition of what space
is or tell you whether it's a physical
object or a concept again because they
never Define these words these crucial
words if you're going to talk about
space first thing you have to decide
whether it's an object or a concept okay
if it's a concept you can't talk about
Infinity because Infinity infinite is a
adjective and you can only apply it to
objects you cannot use adjectives in
science to qualify
uh Concepts okay so you can't say that
love is red
okay red can only be applied to
something which is physical not to a
concept your intelligence is uh great no
you can't do that not in physics okay
and here are others you know Pedro
Fonseca and you have uh there talito I
like his name talitas okay
uh the toilets
and others you know and all these people
from the age of uh scholasticism they uh
they they try to analyze what was space
but they never figured it out again
because they lack definitions and around
the same time a fellow who read them all
was Descartes okay Rene descarn this is
his take on uh on Space which is
essentially Aristotle's space is a
plenum okay plenum is a space or all
space every part of which is full of
matter okay so he says space is full of
matter that doesn't tell me what space
is it just tells me a property which is
space is full of matter that doesn't
tell me what space is what fill space is
The Ether
aha the famous ether
and so this is from uh who knows a lot
so we're all those people who say Oh
Billy you don't know what the ether is
listen carefully it's you who doesn't
know what the ether is okay listen
carefully to Descartes okay he'll tell
you what ether is either the medium that
fills the interstellar void
okay the vehicle of light is composed of
a closely packed assemblage of globules
spherical particles
okay do we have that just spherical
particles who says it's very small
compared to the bodies we see on the
earth the globules are pressed in
contact with each other and move
outwards it is the transmission of this
pressure which constitutes light that
comes out of that book right at the
bottom and this is what good old
Descartes was talking about okay
particles
spherical particles that fill space
vibration of that is what they said was
The Ether
uh or the Wave light I mean light was
simply the vibration of The Ether but
the point here is that the ether is a
bunch of particles that's all it is that
fills space tiny particles smaller than
anything we we can imagine okay that's
what the ether has always been even to
this day anyone who has another notion
other than the one I'm showing there
doesn't know what the ether is and if
you don't like uh my definition or the
course definition his notion or the
Greeks notion no problem
you you can only do one of two things if
you're a supporter of The Ether or
propose The Ether you either have to
define the word ether meaning it's a
concept and you can't use it as a
physical object or you point to it you
you have a picture of The Ether and uh
drawing a photograph whatever you want
and you point to it and say ether that's
all we want to hear we don't want to you
explaining anything we don't explain
chairs and tables and trees and rocks in
science we don't explain them we point
to them and name them Rock table tree
that's how we do it okay so we need to
for you to point if you think ether is a
physical object
okay you point a name
and if you think it's a concept an
abstract concept
then you have to Define it how do you
define the word in science you put the
word ether colon and then blah blah blah
blah blah you put some words after that
defining the word ether
those are the only two possibilities
either it's a concept or it's an object
okay if it's an object you can move it
if it's a concept you cannot move it you
cannot talk about the motion of The
Ether because we don't move Concepts in
science
I hope they got through some of the flat
earthers out there that
propose The Ether
okay uh here we have um
Mr Newton and he solved all the problems
with space he said I do not Define time
space
and motion as being well known to all
I like that you know he he's not going
to Define anything but he gets the
credit
so he doesn't know what space is he says
I don't Define it because we all know
what it is we're done right great but he
says only I must observe that the vulgar
conceived those quantities under no
other Notions but from the relation they
bear to sensible objects in other words
the only way you can distinguish space
is because it contrasts again against
the object under analysis the one that
you can see
so whatever's around at that black stuff
that's space you know so that's what
he's saying there and then he says and
thence arise certain prejudices for the
removing of which it will be convenient
to distinguish them into absolute and
relative true and apparent mathematical
and common
so we learned absolutely nothing from Mr
uh Newton girl Newt okay uh did we do
any better until today I mean I can
mention other people who analyze the
word but they never came up with
anything different and this is where we
are today okay what is space you go to
space.com and they tell you what it what
space is It's the final frontier that's
what it is
we often refer to our expanding Universe
with one simple word space but where the
space begin and more importantly what is
it yeah what is it and this is what they
answer it says space in an is an almost
perfect vacuum nearly void of matter and
with extremely low pressure in space
sound doesn't carry because there aren't
you know molecules close enough together
to transmit sound between them great uh
bits of gas thus another matter floats
around emptier areas of the universe
while more crowded regions can host
Planet stars in the galaxies great we
haven't learned anything because all
they're telling us how full
space is they say perfect vacuum we
still don't know what that means okay
but we'll find out in a minute here and
so they start uh where does space begin
outer space is most often thought to
begin about 62 miles 100 kilometers
above sea level
passing this altitude blue starts to
give way to Black because oxygen
molecules are not in enough abundance to
make the sky blue
okay so we have a little bit of a
problem because uh these people are
saying that
um you know uh space has an origin a a
starting point that means it has an
ending point I guess what they're saying
is space stops at the Earth
doesn't go right through the Earth
okay so the question is is space a
physical object that stops somewhere
because they're talking about starting
somewhere okay and yeah they're
confusing the the issues because we're
trying to find out what space is and
they're talking about outer space what
what they use on a practical basis for
uh Jets and
Rockets going out into outer space we
don't care about that what we want to
know what space is don't tell me where
it starts because as soon as you say it
starts here then it means that ends
there it means it's a physical object
because it has shape
etc etc right and now you're treating
spaces of physical object you cannot
talk about the start of space
at least not when we're trying to figure
out what space is or whether it's a
concept and so it's confusing the issues
when they say oh space starts here it's
it's uh when blue turns into black
we'll call that the starting point
that's nonsense that's just a question
of volume how much particles are in that
region that's all that is we don't care
about that we want to know what space is
and whether it's a concept
okay and the space.com continues he says
they say no one knows exactly how big
space is
big so it's a big so it's an object it's
a thing it's it's they're talking about
the size of space
so what is the shape of say space I mean
before we can talk about bigness please
draw a picture of space and we'll figure
out how big it is later on but right now
they're saying it's big if it's big and
they're going to use an adjective to
qualify space that means space is a
physical object they're treating it as a
physical object they think space is a
thing okay it's difficult to determine
because of what we can see in our
detectors
this has nothing to do with experiments
it's got nothing to do with detection it
has to do with conceptualization you
have to conceptualize
space you don't have to go to the edge
of the universe and say oh yeah here's
where space ends or this is where it
continues no it's something that you
conceptualize you you visualize and you
say does space have shape if it does
have shape drawing if it doesn't have
shape it's a concept very simple
we can see into space at a distance of
almost 13.8 billion light years but the
universe continues to expand making
measuring space even more challenging
again this is not an issue of measuring
so these people could have saved
themselves the breadth of saying such
nonsense as measuring space the the size
of space additionally astronomers are
not totally sure if our universe is the
only one that exists this means that
space could be a whole lot bigger than
we think we have a problem here because
they have all these multiverses and
that's a problem because if every
universe
has space within the word Universe in
other words if each Universe has time
matter space in the Hoshi bang what we
want to understand is what is between
two of these universes what are you
going to say space if you say space and
it's the same space as the one that's
inside the universes meaning there's
only one space in the universe meaning
there are no universes you're talking
about clumps of matter which are
separated by space that's all you can
say so you know this notion that uh
there are universes either there's one
space or there's many spaces and if
there's many spaces you got to tell me
what's between the spaces that uh each
universe is in
in other words these islands they have
matter and space what's between the two
islands hopefully not space
and says the majority of space is
relatively empty again they're talking
about the emptiness of space we don't
care how empty it is or how full we want
to know what space is which just stray
bits of dust and gas floating around the
universe as a whole is inundated with
what is known as the cosmic microwave
background radiation right which is
essentially the leftover radiation from
the explosion most commonly known as The
Big Bang
then they tell you that actually Big
Bang is not an explosion even though the
word Big Bang or the term Big Bang
suggests it is so we have all these
contradictions okay they say no it's not
an explosion oh what is it I thought it
you're describing a hand grenade you
know Ground Zero and goes boom and all
these
uh whatever's energies just pop out of
the singularity
that sounds like an explosion to me but
anyways these people uh treat what did
they talk about the bigness of space
they talk about it starting here and
ending over there
so they confuse a lot of issues we want
to know and they talk about how empty it
is all that nonsense or measuring it and
detecting it none of that has anything
to do with the question the question is
what is space either defined
or point
if you think it's a physical object you
point and say that space and hopefully
we see some shape on the screen whatever
you shape you want to give it and you
have to identify what's on the outside
of it giving shape because without that
you do not have
um
you do not have an object
and that's if you point and say space
and then on the other put the word space
colon and you define the word with other
words very simple it's black or white
it's on or off yes or no
okay uh
let me get this
uh
in a second here
's the Wikipedia version
of what space is says the expanse that X
that exists beyond Earth
the expanse what is an expanse
is expand something that is expanding is
that what an expanse is
what kind of nonsense words they invent
to define space I mean if space is
definable it's a concept first of all
the expanse meaning something that is
expanding I guess that's what they're
referring to again uh suggests that
space is a concept and not that it's a
thing but if something is expanding
they're talking about some you know a
physical object that can only be
expanding Concepts don't expand you know
love does not expand intelligence
doesn't expand especially in uh in uh
Oxford and Cambridge you know the
expense that exists beyond Earth and its
atmosphere and between celestial bodies
in other result they said that black
stuff out there that's all they said
there we don't know what they're talking
about outer space is not completely
empty again they talk about the
emptiness it is near perfect vacuum
vacuum what is a vacuum I mean I like to
know and here uh Wikipedia defines it a
vacuum is defined as a space with as
little energy in it as possible so
vacuum is a space space is a vacuum and
despite the name the vacuum still has
Quantum fields
so what is this nonsense when they say
perfect vacuum or that it's an uh that
space in an empty vacuum or they talk
about the emptiness of the vacuum when
they tell you that even a vacuum has
something in it
I I have yet to see the the empty vacuum
uh or or or have it defined because they
always talk about how much
uh garbage is in a given volume of
vacuum or of space so you know these
people running around just telling you
how full something is they treat vacuum
they treat space as a container and they
say well there's so much garbage in this
region of vacuum of this region of space
and we don't care about that we want to
know you know what is space what is the
vacuum
what are you talking about when you say
vacuum when you say space
and again they talk about low density
particles predominantly plasma again
nonsense they they talk about a lot of
stuff that's in that region we don't
care about that we want to know what the
vacuum is we want to know what space is
they talk about the temperature of outer
space how can space have temperature if
it's not a physical object if it's a
concept you know then it cannot have uh
temperature or any properties of that
nature and then they talk about the
again uh says but even galaxies in star
system consist almost entirely of empty
space what is empty space
what is space before it's empty
okay so we have a problem you know with
all these people because uh they never
defined a word they don't tell if it's
an object or a concept okay and here let
me show you uh how we're going to
analyze this real quickly for you to
figure it out okay that they've got a
problem here we have two regions okay I
separated them with a white line one
region has more particles than the other
so you have space with more particles in
space with less particles uh you want to
call it vacuum uh void no problem so we
have vacuum with more particles and
vacuum with less particles
okay so forget about the particles all
they're saying is how many particles are
in each region in this volume okay
forget about it we want to know what the
black stuff is what is the black stuff
don't tell me how many particles there
are in there don't tell me you know this
is more vacuum here and less vacuum
there tell me or more space here less
space over there we want to know what
the black stuff is please define or if
you think it's got shape point to it and
say space that black stuff this is the
shape of space where in meaning that
you're going to have to tell us what's
on the outside of it giving it shape
what is the contrast what is the
backdrop okay
so that's how you have to present the
space until you can do that you know
nothing about space okay and none of
none of these people from the Greeks all
the way to today had any idea whatsoever
with space is and today they treat it as
a physical object because they didn't
Define the terms you have to define the
word object and you have to define the
word concept then you can put space in
one or the other because now you have a
definition
and you just follow the definition you
know like a horse
you just follow the letter of the law
okay okay so here's our Universal movie
version of space and what are we saying
space does not fall under uh the uh
abstract Concepts down at the bottom uh
which are Dynamic it's uh an abstract
concept which is static space does not
move
okay and that comes back to a little bit
to Aristotle who
set in motion and idea that was uh
hatched by a lot of people later on in
in throughout the years centuries and
that was that you know you have the
river
okay and the river has water flowing
okay so far so good and we have a boat
on the river
but the Rip but the boat is tied to the
coast you know some Pole or whatever so
the boat doesn't move
so the river is space
okay the river doesn't move what moves
is the water along the river
so we have two things we have this water
okay
you can call them maybe locations that
are moving uh
places that are moving
but space is the river
okay and that doesn't move it's like you
have an ocean or a lake
the water moves there's a flow of water
but the flow of water is not the ocean
or the lake the lake is the
space
and it doesn't move
but the water moves and it tends to push
the boat but the boat doesn't move
because it turns out that it's stuck
it's tied to the coast and so the boat
remains in place so to speak
and so these are the Notions they wanted
to separate all the way to the Descartes
and Beyond
they had all these Notions of you know
uh the the you move you know the
question was motion and one issue was
you know if the if you're on a boat that
stuck to the coastline
you know um
you're not moving with respect to the
coastline because your boat is stuck but
you inside the boat you're moving around
you're moving with respect to the walls
inside the boat and so are you moving or
are you not moving because the boat is
not moving with respect to the coastline
but you're moving within the you know
the com confines of the boat and so they
had all these issues on you're moving
but you're not moving
so they they got into all these
so-called philosophical things they just
ran around in circles for quite a while
until they got tired and they created
all these scenarios which just confused
them even worse it had a lot to do with
motion
okay so here it is here's the rundown
okay
um again space is a static concept fits
in a single frame of the universal movie
okay space is the black stuff it's not
the little dots which are supposedly the
matter could be uh galaxies could be
atoms could be anything there but the
black stuff is what we're going to call
space and it's a static concept okay why
because uh first of all uh it's not an
object therefore it cannot move okay but
it's a static Concept in the sense that
the word space does not in embody motion
that's where it's a static concept
whereas the ones at the bottom motion
plasma ether energy etc those embody
motion that's why we call them Dynamic
Concepts the ones on the top are static
Concepts
okay and so here it is uh we have uh
this uh analysis okay something that
which has shape okay we have to Define
these words what is something that which
I shape what is nothing nothing is that
which doesn't have shape and one of the
synonyms is
space
space is that which doesn't have shape
if it doesn't have shape it's not an
object it's not a thing
okay that's why you cannot say that
space is infinite because infinite is an
adjective adjectives in science in
physics can only be applied to objects
to that which has shape things okay you
cannot apply it to Concepts
you cannot say that intelligence is
unlimited you cannot say that uh
information is infinite you cannot use
those words to qualify Concepts not in
physics in ordinary speech you can say
whatever you want okay but not in
science
okay and here we have distance
separation between objects location is
the set of distances okay one object to
all the others right motion two or more
locations right and then we get to exist
something that has location
it has to be a something it can't be a
nothing okay it can't be a concept it's
got to be a something
only some things can have location okay
so the something has location by
definition it exists now you can use the
word exist and say this something this
rock exists why does it exist because
it's something a rock in a shape and it
has location it has distance to every
other object in the universe now you can
say that rock exists by definition not
because you believe that the rock exists
but because it follows the definition
okay the space exists
well it's space a physical object
the answer is no we're done
we don't have to go beyond that but just
in case you know uh space doesn't have
location space doesn't move etc etc etc
why because it's not an object
so if it's not an object it doesn't have
distance location motion not a and
existence you cannot say that space
exists in ordinary speech yes you can
say whatever you want you can say oh
space exists love exists information
exists you can say whatever you want
over there in science in physics we
might have to be very careful especially
with a word exist
you heard the name of my book why God
doesn't exist
it's got very little to do with God it's
got to do with the word exist physics is
the science of existence
okay physics only tries to elucidate
that which exists and uh so yeah space
is one of those things that does not
exist you cannot say space exists not in
physics not in science you can do so in
ordinary speech if you want but not in a
rational language you cannot use the
word exist consistently if you apply it
to Concepts
okay
uh we have our science critic
and he was dealing with prophecy and uh
predictions he thinks they're part of
the scientific method okay let's find
out if that's true so here let me put
them on for you okay
listen carefully here it is here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
today include
is a prediction the same thing as a
prophecy
and does predicting play any role in
science
is a prediction the same thing as a
prophecy I would say no a prophecy is a
type of prediction but a prediction
isn't always a prophecy usually
prophecies contain connotations of the
supernatural but you don't need to have
Supernatural powers in order to make a
prediction thus predicting play any role
whatsoever in science yes it does
because if you have a hypothesis that
you want to test you need to go okay
what is The Logical outcome of this
hypothesis
teased it and then if that matches the
prediction well then your hypothesis is
valid
okay so uh you can see where he's coming
from and this analyze what this uh
portfolio says uh he he thinks that
um predictions
which are no different really than
prophecies except a tiny bit just a very
tiny bit different uh prophecy is an
open-ended
type of prediction in other words you
don't give a date time when something's
gonna happen you say the world's going
to end
okay yeah so uh what do you mean by that
well yeah it could be tomorrow it could
be in a billion years so you know
there's no way to really verify what you
said has any meaning okay prediction on
the other hand is a little more specific
you say look tomorrow at two o'clock
there's gonna be an eclipse of the Sun
okay so two o'clock tomorrow you wait
and there's the eclipse okay your
prediction came true so in that sense
prediction prophecy are not the same
prophecy is typically used for uh very
general uh statements but it has not
really anything to do other than
historical or traditional to do with um
with uh Supernatural
okay there's there's no requirement of
Supernatural okay so let's look at this
this is the our good old fellow and he
thinks that uh prophecies or better yet
he calls them predictions uh are part of
the scientific method of course we're
going to argue that they have nothing to
do with
science prophecy Supernatural now not
necessarily prophecy will tell you
what's going to happen and that's what a
prediction does it tells you uh you know
what's going to happen but the only
difference is one is open-ended time
wise the other one gives you some time
or that the event is going to happen
like if you know I let go of a pencil
and say look it's going to fall to the
floor well I can tell you not only
that's going to go to the floor which
could be uh Timeless in the sense that I
don't have to tell you when it's going
to happen or how fast or anything like
that I can just say it's going to fall
to the floor and that's sufficient
because I can test that right now if I
wanted to right prediction uh is more
like that prophecy is more open-ended
you know you're just giving a very
generic uh statement that you know has
no validity it's just an opinion that
something's going to happen someday
sometime whenever
okay but uh more important here is uh
this Hall has misconceptions of what a
hypothesis is hypothesis is not a
prediction an explanation tentative
guess
issue to be explored none of those
hypothesis is an assumption assumption
includes the objects the definitions and
the statement of the facts
um that precede a theory any theory that
you're going to present
we don't test assumptions in science so
I don't know what this was talking about
testing assumptions and then
um if he talks about something being
valid well that's an opinion A belief uh
he believes that he proved it somehow
you know that it's valid valid meaning
he's gonna
bless it and say this is correct
or wrong or whatever and that's not the
case in science okay in science we don't
prove it's religion that proves why
because religious is in the business of
persuading and converting so uh yeah the
problem is unless he defines what a
hypothesis is we don't even have a
common ground uh and again you know
there are so many Notions of the word
hypothesis today that if the guy just
warmed the seed in college well he's
just going to repeat whatever he
memorized you know whatever he learned
by Road uh we need someone who uses his
brain to discuss the issue for that he's
got to start by defining the word
hypothesis and until we get a handle of
that we have no idea what he's referring
to when he says that he's going to test
the hypothesis and if he tested it and
finds that it to be valid whatever that
is you know his opinion then he has uh
proof
yeah he can tell you that his hypothesis
which I guess he confuses with a theory
explanation is uh correct
meaning he blessed it to be correct on
his own
so that's where he ends this poor
problem
okay let's get to some of the um
questions that uh people asked since
last time uh questions comments one file
says physical interpretation of
psychology can you take the format the
arrangement of atoms in a brain and
explain from a physical perspective the
cause the mechanism underlying the way a
person thinks Katie's atom is
abbreviated is an abbreviated
explanation rational
well yeah all all explanations
[Music]
are can be irrational it depends on how
much detail you want which is what
you're asking there it's a question of
degrees for example a child uh maybe
kindergartner or maybe someone in uh I
don't know Elementary School can explain
something to a given level and his
explanation is rational up to that point
he hasn't explained more detail he
doesn't know or he doesn't understand
more than that and that's okay nothing
wrong with just explaining to a certain
point because you can't go beyond
because either you haven't explored or
you haven't thought about it or whatever
you simply lack understanding
uh but as far as the first part uh
interpretation psychology you know
whether if we could see inside someone's
brain you know like God can end you know
all powerful all-knowing and he looks
inside your brain he sees all the um
uh connections all the ropes twirling
torquing Etc he sees all that
can he know from the arrangement of all
those wires we'll call them uh what
you're going to think next or what
you're thinking about can God you know
all knowing god who sees all those
atoms and in every cell in your body and
especially in your brain can he figure
out what you're thinking or what you're
going to think next or what you thought
about you know
last you know an hour ago
and again
um I think it was LaPlace who who
mentioned something similar that if he
could know
all the um
you know where everything else
everything is in the universe every
little tiny atom right
then maybe he could predict what's going
to happen next
because now he has this knowledge of
every little atom in the universe it's
like you have God's brain God's computer
brain or whatever that can keep track of
every single atom in the universe then
yeah I guess you could but because you
would think that you know certain
combinations produce certain results
but you know I'm I'm not into that I'm
not into psychology or a Psychiatry I
don't care about all that stuff at all
you know and I think it's conceptually
possible if you had the mind of God if
you had the computer brain of God knows
where every atom is but you know it's
it's it's a trivial exercise because we
don't and we never will have that sort
of understand uh knowledge or you know
we won't know where every atom in the
universe is and what each one is doing
and how a bunch of them affect this or
that
it's um no computer will ever figure
that out you know it'll break before it
does
okay so yeah you're asking a question uh
that's beyond
anybody's guess it's like asking you
know
uh what's on the other side of the
universe
well you can only imagine you can uh
simulate and say well if physics Works
more or less like it works here maybe
this is what's on the other side of the
universe will you ever go to the other
side of the universe or you know and
check it out the test if your theory was
correct I don't think so okay so
don't even try okay
okay another fellow says Aristotle would
say that stuff has the potential to be
split uh-huh
saying that because it can be broken
then that means it was made of pieces
would now imply that the object has a
contradictory or even infinite
collection of parts in actuality okay
that's something Aristotle is saying or
would be happy with given he abhorred
most actual Infinities and holding to
this would be intellectually worrisome
well this poor fella doesn't understand
much about anything okay
he doesn't understand that all all 150
percent of them right geometric figures
are made of points the line is made of
points every plane is made of lines
which is made of points every cube is
made of planes which is made of lines
which is made of points
how do you think geometry got started
they broke up the the cube into little
what positions points locations whatever
you want to call them they broke it up
in pieces because they started putting
lines in there to calculate angles
how can you calculate angles unless you
break up your you know Cube conceptually
right into little pieces
so even good old Airy would have to
agree with me
that he broke up his one piece single
piece Cube
in the little pieces because there's no
other way he could do geometry which is
what the Greeks all claim to excel in
okay so yeah all cubes all planes all
solids all planes all lines are made of
points they're made of parts and so they
have a contradiction begins on the one
hand it's supposed to be smooth made of
a single piece and then the other in
order for them to do something with that
Cube they have to break it up into
pieces
so they have that contradiction and so
yeah area would have to agree with me
that uh his cube is made of Parts no
matter how he looks at it otherwise he
could be doing geometry
okay and finally we have another file
here if I can get him in the right place
yeah
there it is places are what has location
in local in in reality
uh no
place is a concept Concepts don't have
location
that's why we need absolutely need to
Define these words you start with object
that which has shape
distance separation between objects
location the set of distances now you
can if that's what place is then clearly
it's a concept and you cannot take about
talk about location having location
okay so uh think again now places are
Concepts you can only talk about the
location of objects never of Concepts
and with that I hope I'll see you next
time